مناورات مشتركة وتزداد المناورات
وتجارب الاسلحة في العالم فهل
تزعج العالم وتزرع الخوف لدى
الغرب واسرائيل وامريكا تجريان
ازمة الامن الغذائي عالميا.
كوريا في طور تجربة نووية قد
البنك الدولي يضخ ثلاثين مليار
دولار في محاولة لمنع استفحال
الاسرائيلي ان منظومة القبة
الحديدية اطلقت صاروخين على اثر
بلدة اسرائيلية خيمة للحدود حيث
طلب من سكانها التزام الملاجئ.
على حدودنا حسب تعبيره. قال عضو
الكنيست احمد الطيبي لدى كلمة من
الابيض يعمل على تزويد اوكرانيا
بصواريخ متطورة مضادة للسفن
بحسب وكالة انباء فيما ترد
اوكرانيا باشتراط انسحاب القوات
الانضمام فلا للدول الاخرى
قبوله. اما الرئيس الامريكي جو
المنيتر ما يقصد بها المدمرة على
الخطوط الامامية في حرب اوكرانيا
الممكنة. للمرة الاولى منذ بدء
الحرب الروسية تستخدم مدرعات
استعدادها لتحرير اراضيها التي
تحتلها روسيا بكل الوسائل
الجنسية. وكان جاي لاعب نادي
باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي لم
يرد على الاتهامات حتى اللحظة.
مع ان التقارير تقول بتغيبه عن
جو بايدن لكييف. روسيا تشترط رفع
العقوبات عنها لفتح الاوكرانية
يهدد اي طرف. روسيا سنرد
بالايجاب اذا ارادت اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا باربعين مليار دولار
تأكيدا للدعم الذي وعد به الرئيس
العودة الى مفاوضات جدية وفعالة.
الكونجرس الامريكي يوافق على دعم
حدة الصراع بحسب وكالة قالت
سرايا القدس ان المقاومة
الى قاعدة الاجماع داخل حلف شمال
الاطلسي. وهو اذا رفضت دولة
على المنصة مخاطبا النائب ميراث
بن اري انت حتالة ولن اسامحك على
السويد وفنلندا هما الدولتان
اللتان تأويان الارهابيين. مشيرا
والتطورات. الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية تتهم روسيا باستخدام
الاسلحة الاكثر قوة التي يمكن ان
تغرق السفن الحربية الروسية من
الروسية من اجل استئناف مفاوضات
السلام قال مسؤولون ان البيت
تجريم التواصل مع اسرائيل او
اقامة علاقات معها او فتح مكاتب
تناقش الاجسام الطائرة حيث عقدت
اللجنة الفرعية للاستخبارات
خطوات الموافقة عليها بينما ليس
هناك اي علاقات تجارية او سياسية
مع جايه الذي حظي ويحظى بدعم
وتضامن الكثيرين حول العالم.
وثلاثين جنديا اوكرانيا استسلموا
في مجمع في حين اكدت كييفي
يحضر المباراة الاخيرة لفريقه
بسبب عدم رغبته في رفع شعار
بايدن فقال ان انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي لا
نفس المناسبة في العام الماضي.
السلطات الفرنسية تجري تحقيقها
وفقا لصحيفة نيويورك بوست.
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
الموافقة على هذا القرار? الحرية
لدى الغرب. حملة تضامن واسعة مع
على حاملي الاسرائيلية المشروع
قيد الدراسة بانتظار اكتمال
الاطباق الطايرة. جلسة هي الاولى
من نوعها بمجلس النواب الامريكي
اللاعب السنغالي ادريس جاي بعد
اتهامه برفض مكافحة رهاب المثلية
المختصة بمكافحة الارهاب التابعة
لمجلس النواب الامريكي جلسة
للجزائري مع اسرائيل وهو موقف
الشعب الجزائري ايضا. فهل يتم
التواصل الاجتماعي في العراق
والدول العربية جورج بوش قالها
الهوية او ما يعرف بالاجسام او
الاطباق الطائرة هذه الجلسة ليس
اثارت اللسان هذه ضحك جمهوره
لكنها اشعلت الغضب على منصات
واضح طبيعة الادارة الامريكية
يعد ذلك شيئا جديدا للعالم
علنية للمرة الاولى منذ عقود
لمناقشة الظواهر الجوية مجهولة
زلة امريكية جديدة. وصف الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق جورج بوش الابن
تقدير خاطئ بوجود طائرة كانت
تحوم قرب الحدود اللبنانية من
بمشروع قرار يجرم التطبيع مع
اسرائيل من اهم بنود المشروع
الجوية التي لا تكتفي امريكا
بالموافقة عليها بل تشارك فيها.
خلال حفل نظمته مؤسسته في تكساس
غزو العراق عام الفين وثلاثة
للصواريخ الباليستية هذا العام
لم تجري تجريب قنبلة نووية منذ
اوكرانيا. قبل ان يتدارك خطأه
ويوضح انه كان يقصد اوكرانيا
قولك بانك لا تشعرين بالاسف على
موت شيرين ابو عقله. اعلن الجيش
الجنرال مايكل كوريلا. تزامنت
هذه الزيارة مع المناورة الاوسع
سوريا كان يشكل مصدرا للتهدئة.
واضاف ان هذا الفراغ سيملأه الان
التي يقوم بها الجيش الاسرائيلي
وتدعى عربات النار هذه المناورات
والجميع يتسائل اين ذهبت حرية
لدى الدول الغربية. الاحداث
الاردني الملك عبدالله الثاني
يقول ان الوجود الروسي في جنوب
دون اسقاطها. وقد ادى ذلك الى
تفعيل صافرات الانذار في اكثر من
المتحدة الامريكية في المنطقة?
اقتراب الحرب. مناورات جوية
الفلسطينية قادرة على اشعال جميع
الجبهات في لحظة واحدة. العاهل
اعلن انه اصدر تعليمات للجيش
بالبدء في وضع خطط هجوم ضد
الايرانيون ووكلاؤهم. وللاسف
امامنا هنا تصعيد محتمل للمشكلات
من يطبع مع اسرائيل؟ قلق امريكي.
معلومات استخبارية امريكية تكشف
المجنون ويطلق الصاروخ ليري
واشنطن قوته ويدرك الرئيس بايدن
يجدد رفض بلاده لانضمام فنلندا
والسويد الى حلف الناتو. وقال ان
شمالي. وبينما تجري كوريا
الشمالية عديد الاختبارات
الجوع كاداة حرب قالت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية ان الفا وسبعمائة
للمساعدة في كسر الحصار البحري
الروسي وسط مخاوف من ان تزيد
في كافة البلاد. لاعب سنغالي
يحظى بدعم عالمي. فهل يدرك الغرب
المثليين كما تقول الصحافة
الفرنسية. اللاعب السنغالي لم
خطأه? نائب يهاجم زميلته في
الكنيست ويصفها بالحثالة ودوي
الامريكان في محله ام انها مجرد
ظاهرة وستمر كغيرها. نخوة
والجدل بشأنها وتجعلهما اكثر
جدية وعلنية. هل يكون قلق
منوطا بها ان تشرح او تفسر
الظاهرة انما تسعى لتطبيع النقاش
الجزائر. نواب اسلاميون في
البرلمان الجزائري يتقدمون
يانج صاروخا نحو البحر ويعد
السادس عشر بين اختباراتها منذ
بداية عام الفين واثنين وعشرين.
وسبق ان تعهد مجنون كوريا
الشمالية كيم جونج بتطوير
ترسانته النووية. فهل يفعلها
بانه وحشي وغير مبرر في معرض
حديثه عن الحرب الروسية في
بنفسه واختصر كل التقارير
والتحقيقات والاتهامات وعرف بشكل
ان كوريا الشمالية قد تجري
اختبارا نويا او صاروخيا
للتجارب النووية بحسب الخارجية
الامريكية. ومؤخرا اطلقت بيونج
تمثيل فيها بالاضافة الى منع
السفر اليها وحظر دخول الجزائر
ينقطع فهل تكفي ميزانيات واشنطن
ان طالت الحرب? تركيا تواصل رفض
ذلك خلال جولته الاسيوية. واشنطن
بالرد على اي استفزاز كوري
انفجارات وصفارات انذار في
اسرائيل. فما الذي يجري؟ بينما
وفي وقت سابق كان رئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي فيف كوخافي قد
ايران. فهل تكون هذه المناورات
سببا للحرب بين ايران واسرائيل؟
وتظهر المشكلة في الكونجرس لاول
مرة الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا لا
عام الفين وسبعة عشر. فهل تجريها
بالتزامن مع وجود رئيس الولايات
زال شبح العراق يلاحق الامريكان?
الاطباق الطائرة تثير رعب امريكا
بالتزامن مع جولة اسيوية لبايدن.
كوريا الشمالية تجهز موقع
بمشاركة سلاحي الجو الاسرائيلي
والامريكي تحاكي قصف المنشآت
النووية الايرانية تل ابيب
تستقبل قائد سيلكوم الجديد
فنلندا والسويد والمقاومة
الفلسطينية تعلن التحدي للمحتل
البنك الدولي يحاول تدارك ازمة
الغذاء في العالم. الجزائر تجرم
ايران. فهل يسكت الايرانيون على
ذلك? وهل تندلع حرب بين طهران
وتل ابيب? زلة لسان لبوش تثير
الجدل في العالم العربي. فهل لا
يعد ذلك اشارة على اقتراب الحرب
مجنون كوريا يستقبل بايدن بتجربة
نووية محتملة وواشنطن تتوعد
بالرد. اسرائيل تجري مناورات
مشتركة مع امريكا استباقا لضرب